face à vous jean landi rédacteur en chef
responsable d après-midi d'antenne 2 et
jean vous allez devoir répondre à des
questions concernant les après-midi de
l'a2 précisément et vous répondrais
également aguida rénové qui vient de
belgique qui représente le journal télé
pro à la essayons tout d'abord le
courrier
[Musique]
quel est votre rôle exact en ce qui
concerne les après midis sur antenne 2
parce que je crois que ça éviterait un
certain nombre de questions par la suite
et bien encore en coordination avec le
secrétaire-général au programme et puis
la direction générale préparer des
émissions suivre leur fabrication tout
au long de l'année
et quand les saisons changent
éventuellement changer les émissions qui
n'ont pas eu le succès qu'on espérait en
lancer de l'autre quel titre d'émission
superviser vous l'après midi commence à
peu près avec vous ma chère jacqueline
raison à 14h avec aujourd'hui madame
puis nous passons un feuilleton ou un
film selon les jours ça s'est fait par
les services des feuilletons et des
films puisqu'il s'agit de rediffusions
la plupart du temps après ce que nous
avons à 16 heures autour de 16h 16h30
des émissions qui sont au début de la
semaine libre parcours dirigés choisi
par sophie richard je ne m'occupe pas du
mercredi les enfants c'est tout un
programme
et ça c'est la charge de l'air clean
joubert le jeudi nous avons invité du
jeudi avec des producteurs différents
anne sinclair hélène vide a indiqué le
cas et votre serviteur et le vendredi
c'est henri slot-in qui produit quatre
saisons et nous avons après cela un
magazine du super 8
je ne voudrais pas oublier la charge
l'heureuse est lourde à la fois de la
vérité tofan la marmite qui est une
émission qui passent plus tôt mais qui
aurait pu passer l'après midi et c'est
donc que ce programme de michelle hiver
dépend aussi de ses émissions là et puis
personnellement met en relation avec
robert chapatte sinon je suis bavard non
je samedi at elle dit
bon bah le samedi c'est le jeu du stade
en liaison avec le service des sports 42
ou 44 samedi par an vous reviendrez pour
nous parler des jeux du stade parce que
je crois que les téléspectateurs s'y
intéresse beaucoup
je commence par la question monsieur
ferron de perpignan libre parcours porte
bien son nom mais quel est son principe
le principe c'est de diffuser des
documents existants donc que nous ne
produisons pas mais des documents si
possible de qualité produit par des
sociétés aussi diverses que l'unesco où
l'électricité de france pour donner
connaissance à un public très vaste des
éléments d'information qui sont fournis
par ces sociétés et qui sont donc
destinés à ouvrir largement un éventail
comme par exemple les l'islam et que
nous avons traité ya quelques semaines
ou bien peut-être un jour prochain les
problèmes posés par le nucléaire
mademoiselle dit jean de paris vous
demande pourquoi les émissions l'après
midi sont toujours de la radio filmée il
faut que je demande à cette demoiselle
de combien d'argent nous pouvons
disposer pour faire des émissions elles
sont longues vous avez eu la gentillesse
de dire qu'elles étaient nombreuses
ça fait beaucoup d'heures d'antenne et
quand on veut faire de l'image filmée
composé ça revient plus cher quand on
parle voilà madame bastide de paris
l'invité du jeudi est une émission
intéressante mais impossible à voir pour
les mamans qui à cette heure là sont à
la sortie de l'école là il ya un gros
problème c'est une une lettre parmi
beaucoup mais oui vous savez en antennes
de était la première société de
prévisions issus de lexware tf à faire
des programmes continus de la mi journée
maintenant de la mi-journée et autres
fois seulement à partir de 14h jusqu'au
soir alors là dans ces heurts il y à des
heures qui sont mauvaises
16h bien sûr les mamans sont allés
se chercher leurs enfants à l'école
16h15 30 elle rentre elle leur donne le
goûter ne peut pas rire la télévision
mais est-ce qu'il faut que nous
arrêtions à ses heures il faut quand
même faire une émission à césaire
bon il se trouve que c'est l'invité du
jeu dit il je dis que ces quatre saisons
le vendredi ça pose un problème parce
que le vendredi pour les bricoleurs les
honneurs les pêcheurs façon peut-être
pas là bas alors en moi on me demande de
faire des émissions d'après midi je les
fais l'après midi je ne je n'ai pas la
prétention de dire de 16h à 16h30 on va
vous mettre rien du tout parce qu'il a
personne à l'ecoute bon alors justement
on vous dit vous faites une émission de
loisirs le vendredi après midi pour nous
le loisir de regarder la télévision ne
commence que le samedi alors que faire
la même question alors vous les déplacez
l'émission loisirs du vendredi au samedi
après midi madame ou monsieur c'est sale
c'est we made plusieurs personnes ayant
alors je vais je oui mais alors le
samedi il y à une émission de sport et
c'est un choix délibéré d'antenne 2 de
traiter les sports le samedi et de
laisser à tf1 les sports du dimanche on
à 2h52 sport après les sports il ya une
émission pour les jeunes dont il ya
quand même des jeunes qui sont libres si
le samedi après-midi après ça y est la
course autour du monde qui est à un très
vaste public
comment faire ses antennes 2 c'est une
chaîne on va pas multiplier les canaux
on va pas couper l'image en deux et
c'est bien mais on vous dit aussi à
propos de l'émission d'henri slot-in
acquis votre mission s'adresse-t-elle
aux hommes inutile il travaille c'est
encore une bonne habitude aux femmes
alors parler de ce qui nous intéresse
jusqu'à on trouve que effectivement si
vous avez un public féminin il vaudrait
peut-être mieux parler des loisirs
féminin brisant c'est vrai il existe
écoutez c'est le problème de vous avez
accueilli henry slot-in dans cette
émission
d'ailleurs on lui a posé cette question
nous l'avons ressorti de son dossier
mais oui mais je sais bien et je me
permets de rappeler que la saison
dernière cette émission passer le
dimanche matin et que le dimanche matin
pour des gens qui fondent la pêche de la
chasse du jardinage et canal j étais
comme ci comme ça parce que les pêcheurs
étaient pas là quand la pêche était et
est ouverte et chassent sur les mêmes
choses donc c'est une émission tous
azimuts qui a peut-être une trop grande
ambition maintenant qu'elle dure une
heure et qui est évidemment à des
difficultés à trouver son public nous le
savons nous nous posons les questions
alors ça c'est une lettre qui s'adresse
à l'émission que fait jacques gara qui
est aujourd'hui madame pourquoi
faites-vous l'émission pour le troisième
âge le seul jour où nous sommes
précisément occupé à garder nos
petits-enfants mes gens vous pouvez me
répondre toujours la même chose
vous me dire qu'il faut bien faire les
émissions mais là tout
c'est vrai le mercredi après midi il
existe encore des grands-mères gentil
qui gardent leurs petits enfants pendant
que les mamans travaillent
pourquoi diffuser ou les missions
destinées aux gens du troisième âge ce
jour là oui et bien jacqueline le
mercredi aussi à 14 heures il existe des
grands-mères gentil qui sont tout seuls
bien sûr mais elles sont aussi seul le
mardi aussi le jeudi 6 vendredi
l'avionneur
l'idée de départ elle allait même plus
loin c'était de se dire dans une
vocation de complémentarité dont le
courant a passé un certain moment il ya
un peu plus d'un an
c'était de se dire si une chaîne traite
les enfants nous on va traiter les le
troisième âge on a failli aller plus
loin même et pousser l'émission du
mercredi de jacques gara qui va
d'ailleurs un quart d'heure plus loin à
aller plus loin et se dire le mercredi
après midi on va faire une émission pour
les grands adultes puisque en face on
fait les enfants
finalement les enfants ont le choix
entre deux programmes à 4 heures tf1 ou
antenne 2 on s'est dit pourquoi pas les
personnes âgées en début les personnes
âgées en deux problèmes le premier elles
ont leurs petits enfants chez elle à
garder le second problème c'est que ces
petits enfants sont là ils savent très
bien que sur tf1 il ya une émission pour
eux donc nous qu'une chance de regarder
la télévision cet après midi là vous
savez là vous me posez des questions qui
sont d'ordonnancement général la grille
des programmes qui ne relève pas que de
moi
il faut aussi appelé cette émission
monsieur peu le père qui va nous falloir
nous le ferons a prévu et j'ai lu
reposerait cette question si vous le
voulez bien nous allons passer à la
presse
[Musique]
bidart et nougué de télé pro jean nancy
en fin de compte qui essayez vous de
toucher les après midi nous savons que
le public d après midi et un peu plus
féminin est un peu plus âgé et si je
peux me permettre de dire un petit peu
plus conservateur que le public
d'ensemble de toutes la télévision alors
nous savons que nous avons un peu plus
de femmes un petit peu plus âgé est un
petit peu plus classique que le public
d'antenne 2 e s de maçon là je vous
réponds encore une fois ce que je disais
à jacqueline ont fait des émissions
l'après midi bon il y en a aussi à midi
maintenant sur antenne 2 il ya aussi le
soir je précise ma question exemple
aujourd'hui madame on est en plein dans
le but à 14h les centaines de milliers
de personnes qui regardent jour du
madame avec une fidélité jamais démenti
depuis huit ans par c'est une émission
qui date du temps de la rtf ont confirmé
que de 14 heures à 15 heures en se
posant la question de ce qu'on fait le
mercredi il ya une vocation de
télévision féminine qui est démontrée
qui est parfaitement suivi par les
journalistes de jeu gras et son équipe
et après après un fait divers
divertissements
parce que on va on me reproche tout à
l'heure vous parlez la premier league
bon alors on parle d'une heure et puis
pendant 50 minutes on diffuse un
feuilleton américain qui a eu du succès
et qu'elle n'a encore recevoir aux
chiffres d'audience ou bien lundi un
film qui fait un joli score quelquefois
plus que beaucoup d'émissions qui passe
en soirée donc quand la parole
divertissement après qu'est ce qu'on
fait ou documents lorsqu'il s'agit de
libre parcours et nous avons de très
bons documentaires qui ne trouvent pas
la place sur l'antenne ou bien l'invité
du jeudi dont on peut dire que c'est pas
une mauvaise émission ou bien une
émission composites comme quatre saisons
qui cherche son public
alors vous voyez on part ont diverti et
ont fait d'une mosaïque de magazines on
peut pas parler de l'après midi c'est
pas vrai qu'on parte le brillant qu'on
va divertir tout l'après midi non à
propos de l'invité du jeudi à skis a pas
une tendance à faire du parisianisme
c'est à dire toujours les grosses têtes
qui appartiennent au tout paris est ce
que serait pas le moment de découvrir
des personnalités méconnu ça c'est une
autre formule
et il n'est pas impossible qu'elle voit
le jour ce serait l'inconnu du jeudi 1
mais là l'invité du jeudi la vocation
est de prendre quelqu'un de très connu
comme par exemple en décembre salvador
dali rudolf noureev albert cohen
on sait ce qu'ils sont on leur fait dire
dans une partie portrait et puis après
on leur demande ce qu'ils sont au delà
de leur spécialité
quel être humain ils sont donc il faut
des personnes connues mais je ne
repousse pas du tout l'idée de l'inconnu
du jeudi les dents l'a3 j'avais une
émission qui s'appelait l'inconnu du
dimanche
évidemment c'est pas tout à fait le même
titre or à bord commence pas si on la
fait le jeu d'hier a fait samedi si vous
voulez on va en parler
merci merci genre merci au revoir à deux
maps
[Musique]